je vous ai fait des classiques donc là
je fais un
inéditrice dans des films que personne
n'a vu sur une page wikipédia ah oui
c'était qu'est-ce que c'est un bâtard tu
as trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la salle Vincent le savoir c'est rien
que je suis actrice c'est sur ma page
silence
c'était une access américain
Béatrice elle est incroyable alors
alors tu es con parce que c'est c'est je
l'adore
tu veux pas faire ton voisin quelqu'un
qu'on connaîtrise
non mais tu l'as fait avec un autre
texte vas-y ah bah non mais c'est moi
je peux faire quelqu'un d'autre si vous
voulez vas-y encore une fiche je suis
assez fort pour moi c'est peu importe
sans la politique et je considère que
les gens aujourd'hui veulent plus
pleurer ils veulent rire et moi je suis
actuellement végétarienne
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux que personne ne rigole
il est mort
tu sors pour très longtemps parce que
c'est un hommage et que tu sois dommage
et une fois j'ai donné à mon chien je me
non mais ta gueule
il me dégoûte ce mec une horreur
excusez-le c'est un hommage
[Applaudissements]
oui Béatrice
oui ça va bien
émission
là il est 19h07 on t'entend là et à
Mathieu qui t'embrasse d'ailleurs
raté et que sans toi il est rien
[Applaudissements]
on était parti sur une séquence
d'imitation et là ça parle vraiment mais
oui je sais pas ce qu'il a eu lui un
rideau je crois la semaine prochaine et
Béatrice non a marqué le mec est un ex
one be acteur et animateur qui ne vit
que grâce à Cyril mais il se permet
d'être méchant avec tout le monde ça
suffit stop in English
la méchanceté et l'apanage des gens
malheureux méchanceté
de trouver un peu de paix alors si tu
veux trouver des pets
il faut que tu viennes me voir pendant
qu'ils pour d'accord je lui répondrai là
exactement
on verra on fera la phrase de Paul et Le
Havre le second degré est livré avec
l'intelligence j'aurais aimé c'est pas
des livres ça
me regarde il y a un autre tweet du coup
c'est vrai qu'à mon avis ça va faire le
truc